When people think of the Emory University hospital system,
a lot of things may come to mind, but laundry probably isn't one of them.
"They do not realize the magnitude and how much linen is processed."
Blankets, hospital scrubs, sheets, pillowcases, and more. Today Emory's laundry services
picks up, cleans, disinfects sorts and distributes over
600,000 pounds of linen every month.
That's more than 7 million pounds a year at a cost of nearly $5.5 million annually.
To keep expenses down, most of the enterprise is managed by Emory.
"We service 12 distribution points of service every day including on weekends."
It's an intricate operation with many moving parts.
"If one of the links is not in place, then this
chain kind of gets all wiggly and the patient care is affected by that."
While the rest of us sleep, Emory's laundry staff are busy collecting and distributing linens.
Their work day starts at midnight so they don't disrupt
clinical operations during peak hours.
For the 29-person staff there is love of the job and a good deal of pride in what they do,
as is evident by the low turnover rate in their department, in spite of the arduous demands of the work.
"It's a physical job because of the the pushing and the pulling and the stooping and the bending,
and also the the weight of the of a carts. One exchange cart can weigh up to 500 pounds."
Workers collect carts filled with sealed bags of dirty linens and load them into these box trucks.
The drivers then haul the load to Emory's distribution center in Clarkston, Georgia,
where staff sort and ready to linens for transport to Crothall Laundry Services in Rome, Georgia.
Here, plant employees, with the help of industrial machines, clean, sterilize, dry,  and fold the linens.
12,000 pounds of fresh laundry per truckload is shipped back to the Clarkston facility,
where it will be resorted and loaded back onto the box trucks for delivery to the various hospitals and clinics.